dans notre immeuble il y a aussi une
boutique d'antiquités une élégante
boutique tenue par deux et les grands
antiquaires son enseigne porte ou deux
hortense oui ou non ce qui nous réjouit
depuis le temps que je dis vous pensé au
délai qu'ils ont pâli droz qui sont nos
amis comme impur grande île et opaline
robinson elles sont vendues alors si on
continue à les gens vont à vitré des
clients très convaincant et le poète pas
on va être en proto n'est encore acté
je voulais pas garder frais alors les
deux puis c'est pas d'une rue rabat et
là bas tu n'as tu n'avais qu'à me dire
que quand tu as une option dessus
c'est la mesure qui les a pris en juin
vouloir revenir et finalement elle a
brillé à l'abri des deux parce qu'elle
voulait voir si ça continue comme ça des
envies sur le pont car il a continué en
plus rien à vendre du tout mais si c'est
bien ça d'ailleurs c'est pas sais pas ce
qui se passe en ce moment il ya 1 re sur
l'antiquité je passe plus tôt et voilà
c'est le cas si moi je suis empreint du
makoko la griffe des coups là qu'est ce
qu'on en fait on la jette ou quoi
les coudes ne me pose pas cette question
je t'ai je tenais je t'ai je t'ai déjà
répondu si on n'a rien en magasin ce
beau monde se séparer de mahdia gelagri
la régularité où elle est très jolie
qu'elle avait redorée on apprend à
refuser tout un particularisme -
lampadaires non messieurs c'est tu sais
c'est terminé c'est ma femme romont
romont tout dans interviendrait comme un
client de se disputer avec cette boîte
de cirage que madame les honneurs m'a
demandé de monter en un jour sans
travail en effet selon l'équipe remi
messieurs bonjour monsieur je ne vais
pas vous désirez quelque chose au chai
besoins des différentes choses je
m'installe à ses procès pour ces pouvait
franchir avant attendez attendez alors
alors à ce moment là si c'est pour chez
vous il faut que je fasse des maquettes
je vous ferai l'équipe michael fallait
les décorations je crois qu'ils les
choses comme ça oui alors je voudrais
avoir un renseignement oui
dans ce but là oui j'aimerais savoir en
quoi vous êtes meublé présentement en
charlemagne en charge charlemagne nommé
fin charlemagne à cheval sur fins
charlemagne et directe ou alors ça c'est
un grand cheval de la garde à vue sont
deux époques qui vont bien ensemble
c'est régis petit col du même avis que
moi monsieur vous avez alors la grande
table de pierre alors oui j'ai le menhir
avec sa wii avec des boues qui sera pas
à nyon dont le nom d'un seul bloc et en
somalie
amélie munier c'est très bien entre nous
on est là on l'a fait monter un
lampadaire
nous verrons une merveille de souvient
l'alluré savez mots bien lorsque ses
solistes jolie que quelques courses ça
nous a fait un usage et qui y voit une
autre chance beaux murs a son importance
aussi quand délégation générale vos murs
sont peints ou tapissés comment son
petit maintenant tout en mosaïque vous
savez à la turque
ah oui j'avais conseillé parce que avec
les médias la mosaïque on peut paraître
une faute de choses dans ce camp mais
les vitesses cuir de manière assez
limitée fait quand même un certain
équilibre sera tenseur je vois ça y'a ka
paul louis saez qui puisse aller avec sa
secrétaire me saindon puristes quelques
coups mais vraiment rare oui il a raison
il a raison montredon montredon à
monsieur le petit secrétaire mais c'est
ce qui vient de rentrer en boîte et si
tu nous montres s engage à rien je
tiendrais messieurs je voudrais vous
poser une question vous ne pensez pas
que ce soit trop fragiles non à ça vous
savez sont quand même des meubles qu'ils
ont de sens en éveil convient courant ce
sera évidemment il faut pas laisser
l'humidité non impossible
est-ce que vous avez l'eau courante chez
vous ah oui j'ai le courant tout ça
voyez je me déplace même pas parce que
je sais la réponse et ne supporte pas
son immeuble d'une susceptibilité
monsieur vous pouvez pas vous rendre
compte c'est comme négociatrice est
coincés comme des grands attendez moi
c'est comme des gros buzz or on a failli
avoir happé pas terrible d'ailleurs avec
avec le fauteuil en fauteuil un
cauchemar fauteuil louis xiv va y avoir
des envies d'ailleurs
asseyez vous ça vous qui êtes
collectionneur c'est une bvm pop et
leurs voix aux tests et à l'aubrac dowie
oui regardez vous accomplissez bien
combien de temps déjà aurillac c'est pas
trois mois et demi à 3 francs il n'est
pas moins des calmars rapportent souci
des soucis pas bref à nos jours nous a
entendus à des clients de passage mais
je vous dis des gens pas intéressant
toujours d'une telle attraction de pius
oui le plus grand des clients de fioul
nous leur avons rendu un très beau
fauteuil mais 14
il était attentive à aubagne est
assignée oui tu as signé louis xiv louis
xiv
donc j'ai passé david 14 monsieur frère
du roi il était super bien trop
difficile délicat de sa famille bien
superbe où les bisons des règles
bref le fauteuil ne sait pas plus ces
gens là n'est ce pas c'est à dire qu'on
lui a fait des réflexions des réflexions
méchant non ces gens là mairie dépeint
dans ce fauteuil lui faire aux îles n'ai
pas de style
on a été refait son ambition ne l'aurais
pas acheté quand on est content que ça
demande pas tant devant il faut d'ores
et bien je ne sais pas on ne sait pas
non je sais pas si c'est ça va pas
toujours utiles qui s'est dit à dépérir
a sectionné
il a perdu sa forme et c'est devenu un
tout petit peu sinon je vous vous rendez
compte cause et le staff est on me
demande si je veux pas tout simplement
alors prendre une table en cinq tableaux
il sait d'autre chose c'est autre chose
bien c'est pas maintenant j'aurai besoin
que je pars d'or et voyez monsieur de
toute façon faut toujours faire redorer
oui surtout le ca si on veut que ça va
jonathan spa pelesasa on a intérêt à
faire vous devrez bien sûr et alors
maison ce qui serait peut-être pas mal à
ce moment là je pense à des choses que
j'ai peur si monsieur adopté ce principe
de la taxe ça va un peu dur ça va aussi
ce qui serait peut-être bien c'est une
babiole n'a pas eu non reliées aux
petites choses c'est pas fou ou un petit
détail comme ça qu'une petite teinte
style fendi danses d'époque savoyard
tradition merveilleux et à leurs pieds
et leurs effets elle est ancienne mais
je pense qu'il ne riez pas la même pas
doré sans les motifs n'ont pas de régime
hâtif je sais pour l'avoir magasins en
corée c'est que vous la procurer
marquant la fin du jeûne et de
préférence pas encore semaines n'ont
plus tellement fragile je trouve que
c'est oui ça serait plus difficile avait
même envoyé aux gens même jusqu'à si
elle n'avait pas tout à fait la même
forme et bien j'aimerais autant voyez
oui oui oui vous est fixé sur une
surface 18 alors oui alors effectivement
nous avons nous avons un article 102 rue
emploi vie d'une forme un petit peu
différente 100 ans mais avec quatre
pieds elle me gêne pas du tout seulement
c'est plus une tasse et un escabeau
c'est le seul ennui mais enfin barça on
oui mais j'en ai déjà si vous en avez un
tant pis alors je me suis en mesure non
seulement vous en tahitien ne sais pas
ce que vous voulez vous que je me plaît
je me blesse et inquiète ses
journalistes non mais sérieux derrière
vraie vie mais hier c'était hier sa
colère était battu c'est pour un
hippiques pour un salon c'est quoi
maintenant c'est pour mon armoire dans
la vie j'ai une grande armoire vide
alors je veux la meubler
qu'est ce que vous me conseillez vous
rendre ça les enfants au foyer mione m
décembre comme motif décoratif samraoui
la maison au début des simples moyens
non pas des airs très bien nourris pas
forcément ma faim vous ne craignez pas
que ça fasse un peu nu des centres seul
comme ça au même je suis un coussin vous
pouvez y accrocher des choses mais vous
allez voir moi j'ai suivi d un verre par
exemple ont mis en avant pour quelques
billets de 1000 vraiment faim ou les
versions très bien alors je m'assure la
planche dessus alors quelques concerts
31 ans passés très près ou alors moi je
pense est carrément année sa maison de
bretagne ans norman est il en va des
rues de londres annonce d'emblée sur
demain alors alors alors que je dis moi
j'ai dit ça ne va pas ça ne va pas je
vous donne mon avis je suis d'autant
plus désolé que j'avais un cadeau à
faire écouter monsieur monsieur si on
n'est pas trop pressé on peut peut-être
essayer de vous le procurer ce cas oui
mais c'est un cadeau pour une cérémonie
alors tu vois c'est presque pour un
mariage ou un baptême nous rendait 16 go
une veuve
ah bon vous aviez quelque chose en vue
non pas spécialement petite petite
console pour une bosse toujours les
arrêts très bien mon saint louis xiv
mais ça peut être amusant mais c'est
déjà une dame d'un certain âge
nous avons plusieurs consoles wii
presque est très bien aussi donc je vais
de vous à moi j'aurais préféré faire un
cadeau moins important écoutez monsieur
enfin par la fin des fins dans quel
genre n arrête cette page avait été
demandée ne sera prise avant présent si
j'ai veillé sur les vies des choses
jamais bien j'avais des choses à savoir
quoi on veut dire c'est une espèce de
respect de coin de machin service à gaza
nous tenons en une seule pièce non c'est
dans un récipient insère un empire at
war non plus large une chaise à porteurs
et en plus petit pas mais de quel fils
non je prends pas ça s'appelle comme ça
gagne ton nom avec une queue un chien
non maintiendrait un chien c'est pour
quoi faire et frites
or une fois voilà une poêle à frire me
suis alors dit je sais pas ce qui me
retient bouge tes rapports de cette
boutique
ok c'est que ça c'est rien ça mais ça
sert à quoi ça sert à rien n'a rien
seror or harris et monsieur quasiment
être vraiment que c'est curieux c'est
absolument inutile le faire à sa
solution je vous le garantie sur facture
comment ça s'appelle un sert à rien
d'ailleurs c'est le nom et ne pas
confondre avec le sheikh à tous les
paquets la même forme et on peut servir
à l'enlever pour mille choses à vous me
jurez que ça ne peut être d'aucune
utilité et appelait monsieur c'est
semble égal points sont alors éparses et
le prince sept poissons de l'institut de
contrôle ne sert à rien il a été essayé
de mon avis elle pointe on sait qu'on ne
peut vraiment rien en faire ça ça
n'aurait pas ça si j'étais sûr que ça ne
servait strictement à rien je crois que
je me laisserais alors ôté monsieur mais
je voulais moi bien monsieur si vous
pouvez en faire le moindre usage
moi je vous le rendront et pensait alors
je veux c'est une folie mais tant pis je
lâche a tonné important débat est clos
et je vais essayer je vais essayer à mon
retour demandeurs de vous en procurer un
semblable vous n'allez pas que vous
n'avez pas le même malheureusement
celui-ci est vendu je peux pas trouver
franchement vous cet exploit la parole
chaque fois que je vous demande quelque
chose dont je n'ai pas pris un sens je
sais pas à quoi ça ressemble et intérêts
ainsi qu'à vous avez une boutique alors
revendre et moi quelque chose
ah non mais vous ne me laissez pas je me
suis juré de faire une acquisition
jeu-là fasciste chercherait pas dit si
la motion ne refuse pas la bonne mais
qu'on en a également dans l'accord aura
quelques secondes à rien on n'a rien à
vendre des bons la retirer ou alors s'il
ya sa place à cet article via sa chemise
car saint lois envahie que tu ne vas pas
vous écoute moi dont je suis bon
commerçant moi quand j'ai quelque chose
quelque chose avant john ford va vous me
donnez une idée de quelle époque et il
sait ne méritant mais si tu peux
attention ça va tomber il y attraper tu
veux me laisser l'expliqué avec le
client peut donc à l'époque jean
certaine à quelle époque mois arts
décoratifs
c'est pas une copie non je trouve que
vous allez venir ce qui n'est pas plus
jeunes qui le parraine les montres toile
je ne vous permets pas je suis
authentique vraiment monsieur tout ce
que nous avons ici et anciens vous
l'apprendrez et puis regardez les coins
si vous vous y connaissez vous regardez
les coins pas une moisissure au coin
revient sur les pierres fun en europe et
quoi encore il est piqué l'avez vous et
laissez la variole ce ne sont pas les
verts c'est donc ça c'est très gentil
mais qu'est ce que je vais en faire
c'est fou de manquer d'imagination pour
un grand jeune homme ne votera
j'ai pas moi qu'est ce qu'on peut en
faire une tanche elle le pass comme ça
si j'habite torchère une torchère un
petit [ __ ] de venise comme en noir avec
un flambeau dans les bras dans un
vestibule ce jeu mais nous on veut pas
qu'on paye en noir et blanc rien ça va
pas raciste je suis comme ça et il se
plonge avec difficulté une chose nous
raconter l'histoire de sophie très bien
on veut en faire un très bel exploit il
ya guère changé ce taux avec les petits
tiroirs secrets de riz à nos attentes ou
bien une autre utilisation possible
encore une chose qui vient à l'esprit
coupé en deux peut-être le haut emporte
moto pour accrocher les chapeaux le banc
on porte parapluie une fois qu'il sera
vidé qu'est ce que vous dites que ça au
manque de chance et a des maux fed en
tant qu'humain bon tu as brûlé de terre
bien entendu parce que si vous me
l'apprenez je vous le ravi de devenir le
cas je me dégage la nuque et je vous le
pont s'annonce assez ferme conséquent
même le client est roi il commande on
s'incline
nous n'avons pas droit de ces avancées
trop dur tout ce qu'on a tous qu'on en
vend bon alors d'accord tu me demande
encore une chance avec un bel art à jour
et on n'en pas des avants concours